[Music]  Jenna Dewan Tatum was rocking her  wedding ring just before dropping that  bombshell separation news Oh hours  before Channing Tatum and Jenna  announced their amicable split after  eight years of marriage the world of  Dan's host was spotted out and about  running errands on Monday with her  wedding sparkler in plain sight Jenna  had on a sporty yoga outfit a matching  black crop top and legging set paired  with a camo jacket and cool Sony's sweat  pants in the t-shirt I mean while the 37  year old mom accessorize dwith her  diamond wedding band she left her  massive engagement ring at home she was  last seen sporting both rings in  mid-march at the iHeartRadio Music  Awards there doesn't seem to be any bad  blood between Channing and Jenna the  pair shared in their joint statement  quote absolutely nothing has changed  about how much we love one another but  love is a beautiful adventure that is  taking us on different paths for now  [Music]  [Applause]